how pretty do you need a wifey to be
a wife yeah why six six
seven
sixteen
what's that yeah but remember women are
looking for the eight nines and tens
because we look for twenty percent of
guys so women are more picky than men
are and this is and this is and this is
just two two guys obviously one thing
you need to understand the more
successful a guy is the more he's gonna
literally increase the percentage like
the average dude he he don't matter if
you're five that's good as long as
you're cooperative and submissive he's
good with that but majority of females
are not submissive they carry this
masculine energy about them
okay i think i think what what when you
when you were asking that question pearl
right um one of the things that
a lot of women don't understand about
men is generally
we prefer a woman's character
right so a woman could be
you know there's a thing that says oh
the pretty girls are crazy or you know
the baddies are crazy right for a
long-term relationship that's not
sustainable okay so when you're looking
for a wife
you want a woman who is going to have
good character and a lot of the time
when women have only been shown and told
that their looks are the be all and end
all they haven't had time to work on
their character and so
what it is is that they just think
pretty gets them through the door and
and i've said a lot of women do not
understand specifically
that
when you have a vagina
which you have that's just not good
enough
to sustain a relationship it's really
not and and if you think that your
vagina is going to sustain a
relationship and you haven't worked on
your character that man's going to go
elsewhere of course i agree but then
again it goes back to the point that i
was trying to make
we can say all of that but at the end of
the day women are extremely insecure
because the same way we can say oh yeah
a wife needs to be at least a five but
have a good character you see a 10
walking down the street you're going to
be tempting that's just men the hormones
play funny games and that's why a lot of
men will have beautiful amazing wives at
home and they're out there with side
chicks and that's not because the woman
is not submissive and doesn't know how
to take care of her man the same way we
want to you know crucify women now
because it's that time to put the you
know the lens on women we also need to
look at the fact that men are also not
appreciating a lot of them when they're
not out there i listen i was in a
five-year relationship i have a strong
character but i know how to be a wife i
know how to make my man feel like he's
in control wait can i ask a question
though you said that you go into a
relationship when you're 23 right yeah
see the thing is statistically women and
are literally in their whole phases from
like 18 to 25 so even if you're getting
backed when you're 23 in reality you're
trying to escape
because according to what to the numbers
these times and this is what i say
there's no point in generalizing women
because i from my own personal
experience knowing myself even knowing
these girls here next to me not every
single woman is wanting to escape the
whole life because if i wanted to be in
the whole life i would do it for okay so
then why did your relationship no you
wouldn't do it my relationship ended
this is a funny question because i love
it when people ask me this because they
look at my character and they think oh
it must be because the novel is you know
uh difficult to deal with no it's not i
was actually you think you are no i'm
actually very easygoing and this is the
funniest thing i'm a pretty girl now i
grew up as a tomboy so the boys have
always been the man them i know how to
deal with men i know what men want i
know how they think i can get on with
them the reason why my relationship
ended actually is because i had a man
that could not actually be able to
understand how i can be all of these
cool things and be powerful in who i am
he got jealous of my light and he
couldn't understand that i could be
powerful my femininity and that can you
elaborate when you mean powerful in your
femininity i'm an educated woman i'm
funny i'm pretty sure so
you see one when women say i'm educated
that's when they think i should be the
boss i'll tell you why i tell you by me
being educated is important i've got
three degrees you know
i went from the u.s to the uk your
school is easy here i'm sorry okay easy
it's okay it's easy depending on how you
do it because i was a first class
student because i worked hard because
what i wanted was to prove to myself
that i can put myself into any project
see it through work hardly maintain my
life the way that it's meant to be my
degrees don't make me feel more powerful
than anybody my degrees prove to me that
if i put my mind to something and i work
hard i get the results so i know that
i'm a survivor i'm a warrior i'm a
soldier and that is something that
actually a man should be very grateful
to have because that's the kind of woman
that'll be able to support you when you
have a plan when you have a project
she'll be able to be there for you
are you now telling men what they're
supposed to um
value
i'm telling men that they should value
actually a woman that can help them if
the world was to end tomorrow you would
need a woman
one second that's the problem right
i'll tell you what the problem is
um like um linda said right women don't
know what men want and the fact that you
think you can sit there and tell men
what they should actually want without
actually asking them what they actually
want is the problem okay i'll tell you
how i know this do you know what women
want oh we know what we want we've been
we've been told we've
right you want somebody who can
be a good father
right
um you want someone to support your
dreams if you have them right
did i
you want somebody who listens
you want a man who
like we've heard all of this you know as
men like we've heard it for like
listen we've heard it for decades
let me let me let me ask you guys what
do you think men want oh give me three
husbands because i just i just named
five okay
four out of five men want uh somebody
that can be a support system without
judgment that means that when you come
home and you're having your man problems
you can actually come to somebody and be
that person that lays down and shows
some sort of vulnerability without being
judged because a man is a man bullet
point them bullet point what one that's
one you want you want somebody that can
be caring but listening to you without
judgment you want somebody you can trust
okay two you want somebody that is
nurturing because that person is going
to be your wife is going to be the
mother of your children and your
offspring obviously they have to succeed
in life and you ideally so you want
somebody that can nurture that and
create a home out of a house and then
third you probably want someone that can
actually satisfy not probably definitely
that one that satisfies your needs
sexually no no listen where is the
submission part though wait i was
waiting
for the problem the submission the
submission comes from the part that
where the woman is supportive submission
doesn't actually mean the new winner has
to be below a man a woman needs to be
supportive or he's wrong yeah you know
the same way a man needs to be
supportive you don't know what people no
no no no you you actually don't know
what matters right well i think if
that's not what men want there's the
same way that women want certain things
there's three guys here men then should
we consider as well what they think
women want because the problem is that
people don't feel i don't feel like
people understand what the what a
partnership or unionship means between a
man and a woman there's a lack of
understanding of what you're actually
meant to be doing together so when i
named those four or five things was i
generally right
yeah kind of but not really when you
just i don't know
when you just went on your rant do you
think you were generally right yes no
you weren't
sure
this is true and this is the problem no
because okay so you don't you want a
woman that you come home and say you
know baby okay so so the problem so the
problem is you you think you don't
the problem is you speak a lot but you
don't listen that's the problem
and so when men speak and this and this
has been the problem for like a long
time
when men start speaking and telling you
exactly what they want women find
excuses as to not give the men what
they're actually asking for okay so when
men start saying what they want women
start saying as many of you know i was
just banned on tick-tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible